I'm often asked about the future and
it's a little bit difficult for me to
talk about because as a historian I'm
always focused on the past. When I think
about the 50th anniversary of the you
know martyrdom of Martin Luther King it
reminds me actually of all he was able
to accomplish but those persons who came
before him who also accomplished so much.
You know 100 years before Martin Luther King
the king there were people like
Frederick Douglas for example Mariah
Stewart and others who worked so hard to
get the 13th the 14th and the 15th
amendment passed and then 100 years
later there is Martin Luther King who
through his activism the activism all
those people those very very brave and
courageous people around him
who helped to make the 13th the 14th and
the 15th amendment actually come alive
for the entire nation so that everyone
could benefit from it. So I like looking
forward but it always reminds me of the
past of what we've gone through and of
what we have to do. We have such a
wonderful diversity here on this campus
and in the nation but that diversity
that wonderful community of diverse
voices and experiences and peoples will
melt into a chaos if indeed we cannot
continue to provide a pathway forward a
path where everyone can enjoy you know
the justice of our society. The
egalitarian society and a
voice in what this nation should be and is.